Handmaid's Tale it's pretty it's an
intense show it's a it's a it's a great
show I love that show
handmade still I do I love it well I
think you're not the only one a lot of
people love that show it can get very
intense how do you keep the mood or do
you keep the mood light on the set
because you have it's a you have a job
to do you're all serious actors how do
you lighten the mood on a very intense
scene you know we we joke around a
little bit I mean we're a little serious
but then we I mean that there's a small
group of us like Lizzie who who is June
Elizabeth moss and Amanda who plays Rita
the Mafia in the household we are big
Taylor Swift fans and we really love to
sing Taylor Swift songs in between
scenes so it's so weird to me because
those scenes are incredibly can be
incredibly dark and incredibly moody and
incredibly intense and yet the fact that
they would just yo cut and you guys
would bust in to shake it off you know
whatever it was just wears we were dying
to know if she uh she watches the show
or you know I don't know wouldn't I mean
we we kind of have a secret hope I hope
and dream is that you know how at her
concerts she gets people to walk down
the catwalk with her and you you know do
all that fun stuff we kind of want to do
it as as the females of The Handmaid's
Tale and walk the catwalk one day that's
a crazy it would be a strange happening
for the audience they're in the middle
of a Taylor Swift thing and the cast of
The Handmaid's Tale coming down yeah
that's but we could we could make it
more fun like we could bedazzle the
costumes and put sequences all over out
you know color themes
sure just sort of just not bring up the
fact that some of them are being forced
to have children against their will okay
let's take a look at this clip on The
Handmaid's fail it's just water we could
have you wanna find a Honolulu in an
hour
you never have to go back to Gilead
again
I'm afraid I didn't pack for the beach
you can tell your story in your own
words you write it and we will publish
it
commanders wife would make excellent
propaganda no well spoken commander's
wife do you really think that I would
leave my home people often leave their
homes in search of a better life so far
all you've offered me is treason and
coconuts airs Wednesdays on who Yvonne
Strahovski best of luck to you yes yeah
and we'll be right back comedian Alan
Strickland
you